well i'm pleased to say that jacob bruce
mog who has just left the doors of
number 10 has joined us here welcome to
you we last spoke exactly in the spot in
2019 when you were offered leader of the
house by boyce johnson here you are
again what's your job
secretary of state for business energy
industrial strategy and it's very nice
to see you again i regularly see you
broadcasting so it's nice to see you in
the flesh and how do you feel about that
role it's a fundamentally important role
that the
energy crisis is absolutely the
forefront of the government's agenda
we have to help um businesses and
individuals uh and a package will be
brought forward shortly you have just
been in to see liz trust she has given
you her priorities for you in the job as
business secretary can you spell out
what they are and how different is the
liz trust government going to be from
the one that we've just seen
well it's obviously a conservative
government so the underlying philosophy
will be the same um but liz trust is a
different personality from boris johnson
that
liz is very focused on policy answers
and getting those up and running as soon
as possible and getting
energy into the machinery of government
so the decisions are made and acted upon
quickly this sounds like handouts for
all
help for all for energy bills coming
within days i'm not going to go into the
details because those will be released
into your course but nobody fails to
realize the size of the problem it is an
extraordinary problem
any mp now knows what problems
businesses are facing and individuals
have similarly been facing those
problems but big changes ahead
big differences from the way that your
predecessor did the job there is
literally a lot of work to be done and
on that happy note i'm actually going
over to the department now
i just wanted to ask you about boris
johnson you were a loyalist you worked
closely with him he obviously came out
today you know some suggested that his
hint to a roman soldier was that he
might come back would you like to see
him come back how do you feel about his
passing and the way he went out of
office
i thought boris went out with
characteristic dignity and a plan that
he was upbeat he was positive and he
teased us all by referring to
cincinnati's whether that was to check
our knowledge of classical history or
was an allusion to cincinnatus being
drawn back from the plow i day nay but
boris johnson is a big figure uh has
been a very important figure in getting
brexit down and in our response
particularly to ukraine um i think
enormously highly of him i'm a huge
admirer
but i don't think he'll be coming back
okay as long as he doesn't end up on
some pacific island somewhere at the uh
you know anyway
thank you very much oh i hope lots of
books from boris we all want that
excellent thank you thank you very much
indeed so after the department he goes
the uh the new business secretary there
also one of those tips for that role so
it's going according to plan so far but
from what he said you know the seismic
job now for people like him and indeed
the new chancellor i mean it's enormous
isn't it i mean even in his opening
remarks as business secretary
exclusively to us in sky news it's clear
that two things are very clear the first
is that
the group inside number 10 including and
jacob rees-mogg who would traditionally
be thought of as small state
conservatives who don't favor
intervention of the government in areas
of business and the market are planning
something massive
and
jacob rees book you might have expected
to be slightly uncomfortable about the
idea that we're about to embark on an
intervention within 48 hours that could
cost upwards of a hundred billion pounds
we're getting uh uh towards the scale uh
of how much we spend every year on the
nhs and he didn't blink he didn't blanch
instead he defended it he said that we
understand the hardships facing not just
households but businesses as well and i
think that tells you something about
just how well liz trust is being able to
carry people traditionally on the right
of the party um to solutions that
perhaps uh you would be surprised that
they were uh that they were considering
the second thing is i'm very struck by
jacob riggs mog's rhetoric that lots of
things are going to be different he said
there's a huge job of work to be done